[Music]
julianne hough will Wed hockey player
Brooks Laich on July the 8th the same
day max Markovski and Peta Murgatroyd
get married the two couples did not plan
on getting married the same day a source
tells me that pita and max actually
planned the date and the venue before
five-month-old son Shai was born and
because of Brooks's hockey schedule they
either had to get married in July or
August Julianne and Brooks will Wed in
either Malibu or Santa Barbara max and
PETA will Wed at New York's exclusive
Oheka Castle I just want to have the
most spectacular day all three days
actually we've got three days of party
my source says that Max and pitas
wedding will be huge of course all the
pro dancers were invited bachelor Nick
Viall Ennis fiance Vanessa will be there
along with other former celebrity
partners Amber Rose and nyle dimarco
Max's brother Val of course part of the
wedding party along with pro dancers
Tony Dovolani and Shauna Bergen Julian's
affair is expected to be a lot smaller
and more intimate
I got like lots of family members so
okay they'll all be incorporated somehow
brother Derek will be by her side and
the guest list includes newlywed Mark
Ballas and his wife BCG three must-haves
for the wedding I mean this is obvious
best dancefloor ever best music and
Lexie and Harley have to be a part of it
the little dogs you know doing something
for max and Peeta's wedding shine will
have a special role ring bearer bond
baby he's gonna be sleeping throughout
the throughout the sugar it is my day
for her day Peter will wear two dresses
and the 30 year old has been sweating
for the wedding with some help from Max
and Shai
you